So right now on Instagram,
Meta
is limiting your ability to see anything related to women's rights.
Women's bodies, abortion rights,
elections, social justice,
environmentalism, the list goes on and on.
And they're doing this with a new feature.
It's called Limit Political Content.
What's considered political?
Not really sure. You can stay informed,
continue to see our posts on at feminist
and other posts from all your favorite creators
by simply turning off that function.
Super easy. I'm gonna show you how it's done.
Watch here. Tap the three dots at the top of your screen,
scroll down to Content Preferences,
hit political Content, hit don't limit political content.
Then you're done. It's super easy.